now it's not just politicians getting
harassed by leftist and Tulsa Morgan
Caspar found a hateful note on his porch
condemning his support of Trump I love
bringing in regular people at the deal
with us in their lives so the person who
left the note kept returning
so Morgan confronted her with a camera
great job to find out why she was
targeting him Morgan joins us to tell us
what the harasser said give us the whole
story Morgan
good to see you I see you too this is
like your you're now considered brave
because you support Donald Trump and
don't hide it apparently what happened
no so I I'm a very loud Trump supporter
in my neighborhood there's a there was
Bernie sander posters everywhere and
Hillary posters everywhere so I was like
when I'm gonna put a Trump Trump sign up
yeah well it seems like she didn't like
that and I got hateful notes left on my
porch they threaten me or are they just
like you're a racist you're terrible
they're just like you're racist you're
terrible just because I'm a trump
supporter so you wanted to find out like
who it was you didn't know who I
couldn't figure out who it was so I got
a camera and caught her on camera I
caught her on tape snap it out your wife
is Indian and they said you hated
dark-skinned people yes yeah III happen
to have you know adopted kids and one of
them's from Guatemala so when they when
they say that to me I just laugh I'm
like okay how many how many people have
you brought into your house that needed
help yeah it's funny it's just funny how
they assume and just because I I'm a
trump supporter they assume that I'm a
racist I don't like women all that stuff
it just makes no sense to me but what
what is her if you ever try to dig into
their mind I mean it might not take very
long but I would you know try to figure
okay what is it
about what you were taught to either act
this way treat people this way anonymous
notes it's so wimpy yeah it's sweet I
mean whether especially you see these
back backpack wearing adult man that's
back backwards baseball caps most of
them these you know conservative women
can probably beat them in an arm wrestle
just try just just like actually do an
arm wrestle with them you can definite
and settle it that way but what is it
like it's your generation man this is
your this is you what are you 20-30
years old I'm 28 28 so this is your
generator that's my generation that make
you feel about your it's disappointing
it really is because all my life I've
been
grown up by adults so I'm I'm used to
seeing how adults live not by children
live and I feel like I don't even want
to go back and see where a lot of these
this generation grew up from because
yeah he'd find make me sick
it's infantilization adulthood - they're
out so they're all acting like they're
still in their fraternity I don't want
to work anyone who grow up there
Thursday Thursday night seminars and
knowledge where they can just vent about
how wrong America is you're right thanks
for the story
love bringing in just regular people how
do they deal with being a trump
supporter and in public life where they
don't some people hide it he didn't